♪ ♪
>> Greg: SHOULD WE EMBRACE
BILLIONAIRES IN SPACE?
OR IS IT A SIGN OF DEPRAVITY?
SPENDING FORTUNES TO BE A
GRAVITY.
THIS MORNING JEFF BEZOS
SUCCESSFULLY LAUNCHED HIMSELF
INTO SPACE LIKE A BIG LOOGIE.
THE CAPSULE REACHED 350,000 FEET
BUT THANKFULLY THE RETURN WAS
COVERED UNDER HIS AMAZON PRIME
MEMBERSHIP.
THIS COMES A WEEK AFTER RICHARD
BRANSON FLEW A SUCCESSFUL TEST
MISSION WITH PLANS TO KICK OFF
COMMERCIAL SPACE FLIGHT NEXT
YEAR.
BEZOS AND BRANSON ARE PART OF A
BILLIONAIRE SPACE RACE WITH
TESLA FOUNDER ELON MUSK, WHO IS
ALSO RICH.
WHAT INSPIRES THIS MAGNIFICENT
MEN IN THEIR FANTASTIC MACHINES
BESIDES ESCAPING ALIMONY LAWS,
IT'S NICE THEY ARE DOING
SOMETHING OUR GOVERNMENT CAN DO.
EXPLORING THE COSMOS ON-TIME AND
ON BUDGET.
SPACE TRAVEL COULD BE AVAILABLE
EVEN FOR THE AVERAGE JOE.
I'M A LITTLE SKEPTICAL ANYONE
WENT TO SPACE TODAY.
DID YOU SEE BLUE ORIGINS
OFFICIAL VIDEO OFFICIAL VIDEO
FROM A COCKPIT?
>> CHECK THE O2 LEVELS.
>> ZERO GRAVITY ENGAGED.
THRUSTERS FORWARD.
>> Greg: DID YOU NOTICE CHRIS,
HE WAS DELIVERING AN AMAZON
PACKAGE.
>> Chris: I NOTICED VERY NICE
PRODUCT PLACEMENT.
>> Greg: YOU'RE ON THE WAY.
I AM NOT GOING TO BASH
BILLIONAIRES FOR TRYING TO DO
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO DO.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Chris: FIRST OFF, THEY WENT
TO SPACE.
THEY WENT ON A PLANE RIDE ON FOR
4 MINUTES THEY DIDN'T HAVE TO
WEAR A SEAT BELT.
YOU CAN TAKE A FLIGHT FROM MIAMI
TO NEW YORK ON FRONTIER AND HAVE
THE EXACT SAME EXPERIENCE.
IT'S PROBABLY MORE DANGEROUS
THAN WHAT YOU.
PEOPLE ACTING LIKE THEY ARE NEIL
ARMSTRONG.
>> Greg: I WAS MORE UPSET,
DAGEN, THAT THERE WASN'T A WOMAN
WITH LONG HAIR.
ISN'T THAT ALWAYS THE THING?
LOOK AT MY HAIR.
IT'S ALL OVER THE PLACE.
THEY ARE ALSO ENAMORED BY HAVING
NO GRAVITY.
GET USED TO IT.
WE ARE USED 28.
>> Dagen: WHAT IS THIS HAIR
THING?
IS IT SOME DREAM?
>> Greg: FEMALE ASTRONAUTS,
THEIR HAIR IS ALWAYS ALL OVER
THE PLACE.
>> THEY ARE YOU.
>> Dagen: A WOMAN WHO --
>> Greg: THERE WERE NO PEOPLE
OF COLOR ON THAT TRIP!
THIS IS NOT JUST A SPACE RACE.
THIS IS A SPACE RACE.
>> Dagen: I AM A LIFE LESSON
TO TAKE AWAY.
I LOOK AT JEFF BEZOS AND I
THINK, TO EVERY YOUNG WOMAN,
DON'T TURN YOUR BACK ON THE GUY
WHO LOOKS LIKE MARTY FELDMAN OR
PETER FAULK.
HE COULD WIND UP BEING THE
RICHEST DUDE ON THE PLANET.
YOU WILL REGRET IT FOR THE REST
OF YOUR LIFE IF YOU DON'T GO OUT
ON THAT DATE.
>> Greg: HE JUST GAVE
100 MILLION TO VAN JONES JUST
BECAUSE HE LIKES THE GUY.
I WISH I HAD A BILLIONAIRE
FRIEND, CHADWICK.
ANYWAY, THAT'S NOT REALLY A
QUESTION.
[LAUGHTER]
DO YOU KNOW ANY BILLIONAIRES?
>> Chadwick: I'VE MET A COUPLE
BILLIONAIRES.
THEY ARE VERY NICE PEOPLE.
>> Greg: THEY ARE.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS
FANTASTIC FOUR MINUTE VOYAGE.
>> Chadwick: I AM A SPACE
NERD.
I LOVE SPACE.
IT'S A NICE DISTRACTION FROM THE
POLITICS.
LOOK AT WHAT HUMANITY IS DOING.
LOW ORBIT.
THINK OF AIRPLANES.
STILL ENAMORED BY AIR TRAVEL?
WE SHOULD BE.
WHERE THE FLYING CARDS?
>> Chris: I AM NOT THAT
JAZZED.
>> Greg: WHERE ARE THE DRIVING
PLANES, NOT THE FLYING CARS?
I WANT TO DRIVE A PLANE ACROSS
COUNTRY, EMILY.
>> Emily: THAT'S LIKE MY CAR.
>> Greg: IT IS.
>> Emily: I LOVED THIS.
I TOTALLY CRIED WHEN THEY
LANDED.
I GOT SUPER EMOTIONAL.
I LOVED EVERY MINUTE OF IT.
I SURPRISED MYSELF BECAUSE I WAS
SORT OF A HATER.
I WAS TEAM BRANSON.
BEZOS IS A NERD.
WHEN I SAW IT, I TOTALLY CRIED.
HEARING AND SEEING THE ELDERLY
WOMAN AND 82.
AT AGE 21 SHE COMPETED WITH ALL
THE GUYS FROM MERCURY SEVEN.
THIS WAS A MILLION YEARS AGO.
SHE BEAT ALL OF THEM BUT BECAUSE
OF HER GENDER SHE WASN'T AN
ASTRONAUT.
SHE WAS A TRAILBLAZER HER WHOLE
LIFE.
SHE'S NOW ACCOMPLISHING WHAT SHE
WANTED TO DO, HER TRUE DREAM.
IT'S NEVER TOO LATE.
IT'S NOT TOO LATE.
SEEING HER EXCITEMENT WAS REALLY
INSPIRATIONAL AND I THINK THEY
DID A GOOD HOMAGE TO HISTORY.
>> DON'T TRY TO SHAME ME INTO
HAVING A HEART.
IT'S NOT GOING TO WORK.
>> Greg: AMELIA EARHART'S
GOGGLES?
DIDN'T SHE DISAPPEAR?
>> Dagen: SHE FLEW PLANES.
>> SHE HAD MORE THAN ONE PAIR.
>> Dagen: I HAVE ONE THING
SAVE YOU, SUCKER!
>> Greg: IS AN IMPORTANT
ACHIEVEMENT BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
START THINKING ABOUT EATING
SOMETHING BESIDES EARTHLINGS.
I WANT INTERSTELLAR CUISINE AND
I WANTED BEFORE MY LIFE AND
SPIRIT.
I